so Cobra meeting this morning shed by
David Cameron what should David Cameron
do then about the threat from the
self-styled Islamic state joining us
from Westminster Studios Lord West who
used to be the First Sea Lord at the
minister for security and
counterterrorism as well and Howard
wheeldon an independent defense analyst
gentle never a good morning to you both
Lord West if I can start with you let's
just pick up on the whole question of
strategy it's been quite notable hasn't
it in terms of what's coming out of
Washington the emotions have being
candid Obama's being candid about giving
this impression of how they are making
and still thinking about their way of
dealing strategically with the threat
posed by Islamic state yes I mean I
think that's very clear and I think it's
unfortunate and I hope that the NATO
summit maybe the president might be a
bit clearer in what the Americans are
intending to do but I I think I've got a
couple of things to say straight away
the I don't like this organization of
terrorists being called the Islamic
state it's not a state so I still call
it Isis or ISIL and I think calling an
Islamic state gives us more credibility
than they deserve and I think the other
thing is that although year ago almost a
week a year and a week ago in the house
we decided not to go and bomb Syria
which I think was the right decision
Syria and Assad had no intention to kill
British people or attack Britain the
ISIS organization is in is harming and
attacking British citizens and it does
intend to damage Britain because some of
their people have said that that that is
a completely different ballgame that
means everything is back on the table
and therefore I think whether one uses
force how unused it everything is now
back in the game because I'm a great
believer if a country tries to offer it
someone tries to attack you or damaged
our people then they jolly will get what
they deserve yeah I said Lee when I
remember I always try and call them
self-styled Islamic state but we can
debate that point another time how it
will be very brief because we're
expecting here from the Foreign
Secretary very shortly indeed there is
the danger and Lord West makes this
point there's always the danger that you
start with very limited military aims
but our old friend mission creep starts
to assert itself yes absolutely but I
don't think this will be the case here I
think we will go for it considered
response it's the first thing on the
agenda of the NATO summit which which
begins tomorrow we need in the end a
political response and to get there we
must work through a process of assisting
the curse of supplying them with
whatever we can that falls short of a
full military response so we've got to
be carefully we've got to work together
the Alliance I think will will come up
with some very interesting points on
this tomorrow so I'm very much for
requiring a degree of patience here and
so that we do end up with organ a
consider response backing what the
American out real good I'll interact
very briefly here's the Foreign
Secretary well the US president will be
making an announcement shortly on the
basis of us analysis but our preliminary
analysis is that this video is genuine
that it is mr. sotloff and that it
appears to be the same person with an
apparently British voice that appeared
in the last video obviously our thoughts
are with the family and friends of mr.
sotloff we're doing everything we can to
reassure the family of the British
hostage who was shown in the video you
are loud talking publicly about the
British hostage but have known about
about him for some time therefore what's
happened in the last 24 hours does that
change the mindset to the British
government in terms of your overall
strategy in dealing life it can't allow
us to change our overall strategy we've
been aware of this hostage of course for
some time but we have to deal with is on
the basis of the wider threat that they
pay that they pose to the British public
as well as to this individual in
practical terms what can you do in terms
of attempting to extricate this British
hostage from this situation must be a
limited amount in reality that you can
do well you're aware of course of the
rescue attempt that took place some time
ago unfortunately unsuccessfully you
wouldn't expect me to discuss the
various options that we will be
considering that I can assure you that
we will look at every possible option to
protect this person the events of the
last 24 hours mean that's british air
strikes only closer it doesn't make any
difference
at all to our strategic planning as the
prime minister said we will look very
carefully at the options available to us
to support the legitimate government of
Iraq and Kurdistan in defending
themselves against the threat from ISIL
and if we judge that airstrikes could be
beneficial could be the best way to do
that then we will certainly consider
them but we've made no decision to do so
at the moment are there further Cobra
meetings planned for latest day for
tomorrow can you give us any more
insight about what was discussed around
the table this morning well we don't
talk about what we discuss that Cobra
meetings and we'll have Cobra meetings
whenever there is any development that
it's necessary to discuss thanks very
much thank you for attack thanks poor
interceptor there after the Cobra
meeting being pressed on the question of
how Britain all to respond to the fact
that all these threats now made against
a British hostage held by self-styled
Islamic state let's put some of those
thoughts to Lord West Lord West Foreign
Secretary making it clear he could do no
other in a sense the British strategy
will in no way be informed or developed
by the tragic case of one particular
individual and sad to say that's the way
it has to be absolutely right and of
course we don't pay ransom hostages and
the fact that there are barbaric acts
against our people and British citizens
shouldn't influence overall strategy but
as I said if a group decide to start
killing British citizens and if that
group also threatens our nation it means
we're in a very different game from
intervening for example as in the case
of Syria where a sad was never intending
to do that to British citizens and
things therefore it was a slightly
different case and what we must now do
is look on the diplomatic level we got
to look very hard at money flows we need
even better intelligence of the region
we've got to look how we can fit in with
allies we've got to put pressure on
people like Qatar and Saudi Arabia a
co-ordinated program of how we can
squash this barbaric group of people who
are behaving beyond the norms of normal
human behavior and we need to absolutely
put that pressure on them is quite right
no knee-jerk reactions we shouldn't do
that I think I think I would like to say
that the barbaric killing an execution
of this man that the people who've done
it we will find out who they are I would
like to see them going through the
courts in the
egg but actually I'm afraid there are
some people in the world effectively
they'll become dead men walking I have
no doubt whatsoever that the Americans
will get them I would like to see them
going through courts but you know we
will find out exactly who they are and
they want to be aware of that Lord West
just for I'll go back to how it will do
I just want to press you for any
ministerial experience you've got of
dealing with hostage situations like
this because I'm guessing but from
ministerial point of view there can be
very few things around the cabinet table
for ministers and secretaries of state
to grapple with because a decision can
is the difference with a life on a death
it is extremely difficult and very
heart-rending at times but we have a
very clear policy on this I'm afraid
some other countries don't and these
groups of people I'm afraid these these
these bandits alcohol of what a better
word they see this as a way of making
lots of money although they've executed
these and said this is American attacks
actually they see taking hostages a way
of making lots of money when people pay
ransoms sometimes very big ransoms all
it does is helps and get more weapons
communications gear and encourage them
to take further hostages is a barbaric
way of behavior and they need to be
squashed Lord West and Howard wield and
thanks both very much indeed for your
thoughts this morning we've been
listening to Philip Hammond the Foreign
Secretary referring specifically to that
abortive American attempt to free not
just American but British hostages as
well let's recap what he had to say well
you're aware of course of the rescue
attempt that took place some time ago
unfortunately unsuccessfully you
wouldn't expect me to discuss the
various options that we will be
considering that I can assure you that
we will look at every possible option to
protect this person